[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about hadou key so hadou key
techniques in Aikido or disentanglement
techniques how do we get out of someone
trying to hold us so remember if someone
grabs us in Aikido we don't want to just
grab them better than they're grabbing
us we want to get the heck out of there
so when someone grabs tonight you know
how do we separate ourselves from them
and that's the idea of hold okie today
we're going to talk about an important
hadou key which is moral authority so
more with it always a two-on-one grab
psyche the sense they really like to
work with this technique it's
interesting though because it doesn't
appear in the earlier work of us Eva so
most these techniques are probably more
modern and maybe you haven't never even
worked on them hard to say so we're
gonna talk about that today and get into
some of the nitty-gritty of more okay
dorri I'm gonna get Josh out here we're
gonna go to work Josh all right we're
gonna talk about Moreau fedora Smurf it
always an interesting technique it is
not commonly seen in really old like you
know so if you go back to the first
training manual of the Kobuk con we
don't see Midori techniques appear so
it's interesting why would work they'd
already appear well probably because
he's trying to get dominant control over
one arm probably because I have a weapon
in my hand so I understand that if I
have a weapon like this and Josh grabs
one hand well that's all good and well
but Josh would like to get that second
hand on there because now it really has
the ability to actually control me so
it's a two-on-one grip now what's he
going to do from this two-on-one grip
well he's probably gonna try and control
my elbow and drive me down right so like
he's gonna get to this position he's
gonna start driving me down and this is
how we classically see the Moreau Theory
technique applied in i cuter situation
so when he's got me like this my number
one problem is my elbow my elbows locked
down so let's say I try to switch so I'm
gonna put the weapon hand in this as I
do that he just drives into that elbow
it makes it really impossible for me to
get in there and switch my weapon hand
Hey he also has the ability to drive
into me here so he's essentially got a
rope field going and maybe you can drive
me down it's a good strong position for
him so the fact that he has my elbow has
put me in a bad way
so what do I want to do I need to get my
elbow on under control first thing I'm
gonna try to do is drop my elbow
straight down like this so what I'm
doing is I'm driving my elbow down I'm
not trying to bite was this way he's
doing he's pushing into me this way so
I'm actually kind of joining with this
force and driving my elbow down take to
get a little position there so I'm here
like this now if I were able to get just
this I could probably switch and then
use my knife to get me the rest of the
way free that might not always be
possible though depend on what's going
on I might not want to risk switching
the knife hand so from this position
what will I do well this does a lot of
great things puts him in a bad position
if he was fairly rigid with his grip
when I did this this might happen which
would be hadou key in and of itself
right so that movement can be a Hadopi
clearly all by itself but let's say he's
real flexible with this hand which is
the easy handle be flexible with but not
as flexible with this hand so as I drop
we'll get this position I can put one
into the other hand we can do G nage for
that right so I'm juju now being this
guy right let's say as we do this I come
in here he stuff both me still got me
now we have Nico's in here to clear we
have 8 cubes in here to clear all kinds
of great stuff but let's say we have a
nice deep position and he's wanting to
come around I will step into this and
that gives us Chloe not against a
classic technique like you know is
Moreau Theodore at cookie nugget I drop
the elbow I get inside my Seidman she
threw this guy classic technique right
that's a big Aikido technique and it
comes up a lot because of this situation
let's say from here he already starts
dominating over this way what am I going
to do
I'm gonna run through this and get my
approach right so here let's say josh is
coming around this way and I coming here
gonna get my approach right there and
pop him off this is my approach will
lead us to a whole bunch of other stuff
but that's the basic concept when I'm
working the elbow down I'm going to try
to put myself back here if he's cutting
that off by running this way I'm gonna
set up all the techniques over here that
I can if his grip becomes weak I'm gonna
use that to pop myself free okay now in
this what can he do to make it worse for
me well instead of just locking my elbow
he can twist my elbow behind me so he
can twist it like standard to a hammer
locks into a hammer lock that behind me
like this is yeah
twist that arm so as I'm doing it he's
twisting it up here behind my back now
if I tried to directly fight him in he's
strong
so as he's twisting it up here so like
this and this is what the guy is doing
is twisting that arm just like that so
you just really twisting it over so as
he's twisting my arm over like that this
oh and if I try to fight this guy he's
stronger than me I'm gonna lose that so
what I do instead is I go perpendicular
to his action like this so let's get
real slow so as Josh was twisting my arm
this way I'm driving perpendicular to
his action and I get over to this
position this leads us to all the same
escapes that we had before so he's not
just pushing my elbow straight he's
twisting my arm like this now instead of
trying to just get that position hold me
what the tricep tranq just to fight him
here I'd go perpendicular to his action
here and that gives me the same madoka
is before so if I can drop my elbow I
drop my other if he's twisting my elbow
I go perpendicular to the force and come
around and give this a whole nother set
up of techniques
Baroque there Dori is important whether
it was in classical IP or not we can't
be a hundred percent sure cyclist since
they did it a lot so probably Oh since
they did it a lot but there's not a
whole lot of proof to be sure that you
did that
however it will be important for I could
as modern context whether existed
classically or not it doesn't matter we
will need it in the modern era as we
move forward I'm Christopher Ryan thanks
for watching
[Music]